this is so funny
Donald Trump has been calling for
protests for days on the basis of his
allegedly imminent arrest and indictment
Trump has been saying protest protest
protest it is time it is time it is time
to take the country back Etc well
protesters did show up yesterday outside
of Trump Tower except they were
protesting in favor of trump getting
arrested
just so funny Trump's screaming to
anyone that will listen you've got to go
and protest you've got to go and protest
there were protesters but they had a
sign saying Trump is guilty no one is
above the law seditious conspiracy lock
Trump up Etc take a look at this take a
listen uh not exactly the protest Trump
was looking for interestingly enough we
bring you this live shot here we know
the former president has called for for
protests in a peaceful manner many
Republicans push back on that but
interestingly enough it's the opposite
side that's outside protesting now
saying Insurrection Tick Tock time's up
no one is about the law Trump is guilty
sir the protesters are here fantastic
what do the signs say Sir they say to
lock you up and many supporting the
possible indictment of former president
Trump there
um again what does science really look
like they were made by the Grassroots
various Roots groups too don't they Sean
yeah we'll continue to follow that again
and so the this is a report from Newsmax
by the way the guest here suggesting the
signs that are being held up are two
professionally made
to really be actual activist Grassroots
sign clearly there's someone behind it
and usually the someone is George Soros
I mean you have to understand the
language that's a dog whistle if I've
ever seen one not exactly the protest
that Donald Trump was looking more for
one more thing on protests a group did
Gather in Florida yesterday outside of
Mar-A-Lago and this was in in West Palm
Beach this is really funny MSNBC
interviewed a trump supporter who was at
the protest and she says we are not
protesting we're not and by the way if
Trump's indicted we're not going to do
anything seemingly wanting to preempt
any possibility of trumpists being
accused of violence it's she she seems
not to be liking this narrative
introduce you real fast to one woman who
we met Debbie you were telling me that
you helped promote this online what type
of folks have you done this before have
you had to do you try to get people out
and come out here before I just have a
group of friends and
made and we just get it out to some and
they get it out to some and that's just
how it gets around when you saw Donald
Trump call for protest what did that
mean to you
test protesting we're supporting the
president no protests and if he were to
be indicted what should the response be
from supporters like you nothing we're
just
that's the best what if so what would
people like you do nothing we would
celebrate the arrest it's ridiculous
what type of folks are here today
there you go obviously very hard-working
enough to be out
protesting at 109 pm on a Tuesday as we
know that's notoriously a time when
hard-working people are able to go and
just hold flags for a guy who lost a
recent election and simply can't accept
that so this is going to be super
interesting but I maintain right now
when I take the temperature of Maga
um I don't get the definitive feeling
that they're ready to go and Riot if and
when Trump is arrested and I think
that's a good thing you know a lot of
right-wingers write in all the time and
they say David you want in order to get
ratings and clicks you want there to be
violence and that will allow you to go
after Trump supporters as being violent
and that's you it's terrible that you
want that no no no I don't want that I
don't want that at all and in fact if
you go back to the January 6 2021 Trump
trump live stream that we did uh you see
that I don't exactly look thrilled when
they breach the capital and break in uh
despite the fact that it did generate a
lot of attention I would rather what's
better for the country which is for
there not to be violent outbursts as a
result of the justice system carrying
forward and indicting when there is
evidence to do so that's not an action
that I want to see there be violence in
response to so of course we will be
watching it latest rumor is maybe
indictment today but Trump surrender
next week or maybe nothing will happen
we really don't know but as soon as I
know anything you will as well make sure
you're subscribed to the David Pacman
Show YouTube channel at youtube.com
slash the David Pacman show we have a
packed program for you today and I'm
glad you're here
plastic it's everywhere we look and not
enough is being done about it 100
billion plastic bags are used and thrown
away every year here's something super
simple you can do to reduce plastic and
help the planet a little bit our sponsor
hold on bags is the company making
plastic free trash bags and zip seal
kitchen bags they're just as strong and
high quality as the plastic bags you're
used to hold on bags are 100 percent
plant-based and home compostable meaning
they break down in just weeks not
decades their zip seal kitchen bags come
in sandwich or gallon size to fit all of
your needs whether it's carrots or
crayons at home I put all of my food
waste in a hold on trash bag throw it in
the compost pile and when I throw a hold
on trash bag in my dumpster I love
knowing it's not filling our landfills
and oceans with plastic single use
Plastics harm the planet at every Stage
production disposal decomposition join
the growing movement away from
single-use plastic these products are
really great it's so easy to make the
switch go to hold on bags.com
Pacman and you'll get 20 off with code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below